Of the 7 billion people on Earth, nearly 6 billion have smart phones and this is strange
Considering that 4.5 billion people do not have toilets, why?
Smart machines make a change on your body and your mind?
If you look down at your phone, the back of your spine is almost like you're carrying
A child at the age of eight years on your neck in what is considered to be a lot taking into account
Most people spend an average of 4.7 hours on their phones and integrate it
With the length of time that the computer leads to the spread
Myopia in North America. In the 1970s, a quarter of the population was infected
In short-sightedness, but in the present time almost half of the population are infected, but in some areas of Asia about 80 to 90 percent of the population
Short-sighted
It's hard to put a phone away - take for example the Candy Crash game
Whenever you play, achieve small targets, which causes the brain to reward you
A quantity of dopamine - and each time rewarded with new content. And this content too
Gives you a small amount of dopamine and together this establishes the so-called "loop coercion"
And by chance are the same episode responsible for behaviors associated with nicotine
Or cocaine. The brain is designed to look for creativity, and for this reason existing applications
Our phones are designed to give us new products, making it difficult for us to leave them
As a result, 93% of people between 18 and 29 years old told us they were using their phones as a tool
Avoid boredom, unlike other activities such as reading books or dealing with people around them.
Which led to the emergence of a new term "numophobia" of fear or anxiety
Without smart phones.
We also see a change in the pattern of the brain: alpha rhythms are usually associated with "relaxation relaxation"
Such as when touring your mind, while gamma waves are associated with
Conscious attention. The tests showed that when the phone transmits
- For example when the phone rings - the strength of these waves is greatly enhanced, which means
The processes that occur "waves" can literally change brain functions
Your smartphone can also change or destroy the sleep schedule. The screen emits a blue beam which shows
Change our daily rhythm, making sleep less deep during the sleep period and associated with it
Diabetes, cancer and obesity. Studies showed people who
They use their phones at night and find it very difficult to sleep and produce a small amount of melatonin
- The hormone responsible for the organization of sleep - vigilance rings. Harvard Medical School
During the last 2 - 3 hours of sleep, you should be free of technologia, so read a book before bedtime.
Of course, smart phones have completely changed our way of getting information and noticeably
In the minority range and poverty in peoples, 7% of Americans rely heavily on smartphones
Login online. In 2014 a study showed that the majority of owners of smart phones
They use their phones for banking, searching for medical information and looking for jobs
Since all smartphones are not bad, they were part of a positive change
In the world, there is no doubt that it changed us
If you see a mistake in the translation please adjust the translation on your invitation